foreign
because I understand when you're in
Denmark when people say Dr harpic you
think that they're referring to a
dentist
so I'll skip that and I'm truly happy to
see you because I must admit sort of the
last week I got slightly worried will he
come because he's basically been on the
headline of all the German newspapers
due to a case book called a
big discussion within the German
Coalition about certain issues we
probably return to those issues but then
I realized today ah your timing is
perfect because what has happened today
in Germany is something that even or
what happened cannot compete with Bayern
Munich's
football coach was fired so that is
breaking news also tonight so nobody
cares about basically the the crisis in
in the German government at the moment
not many Danes Master the um German
language
so when you became vice Chancellor I
immediately thought ha
foreign in the Danish German
relationship because now we have a
German Minister who speaks Danish
and maybe we should start with that what
is actually your relationship with
Denmark
um I'm trying to get a compliment that I
speak Dennis and I'm answering in
English but good evening and thank you
for having me
while my relationship with Denmark
started actually when I was studying in
Freiburg and Brisco so this Southernmost
city in Germany I I was born and killed
or I was born in Lubeck and grown up in
Kiel and then I wish nothing more than
to go south
living in Denmark you understand it so I
I wanna I wanna get close to France and
Italy and because I made the decision to
read German literature and philosophy
there is not really a good reason to go
to Italy or France or Spain to study
German literature so I went to Freiburg
and biscal
um this was the the biggest distance I
could lay between my hometown and my new
life
and when I was in Freiburg I left the
town actually it was warm it was new to
France and Italy and everyone was uh we
had a we had a summer
but I realized that I belong in the
North in a way so it was funny everyone
was starting to learn it it Italian or
French
and I was starting to learn Danish in
Freiburg University yes we had a Danish
Dennis a teacher there and she's still a
friend of mine
and yeah that was that was the beginning
and then later on I found out that
little Bossa an Erasmus Arrangement
between fabric University and roskilde
so after one and a half year I was
moving back in the north then to
Copenhagen and studied a year in
hoskilde
and then there was a second phase in my
life later on when we become a writer
couple and our first three children were
born and we really didn't know if this
will work out we had very few money and
the future was uncertain and we lived in
a very small apartment so we needed
space and and and we had we we had given
us
a certain room where we would finish our
first novel and then we would decide if
this was possible to make out of a
living
so then we had the opportunity to lift
in breaths whose is the German for
father
the writer battle question was
fleeing to Denmark when the fascism took
over in Germany and he lived there six
years as sure I'm sure all of you know
the house still exists and it's owned by
the um by the swamper community
and that was wonderful actually then
then I I became aware how much I I love
the nature even the bad weather there
and this was very romantic
and then last step we moved to we yeah
we moved to flensburg we and our near
flensburg and then these mixed culture
Zone the north of physics Holstein
I would say the south of the north
became really something I would like to
call home so then my relationship with
Denmark had a firm solid fundament and
now I'm here we're very happy to have
you here
do you like it
but we'll do this in English
but how on Earth did you end up in
politics
a philosopher you've written many books
also children's books and so forth how
did you end up in politics well the
question I think is how have I started
politics and this was because we were we
we found a house we we lived near to the
dentist chairman Dennis border and it
was the first time after 15 years or
something like that that I knew that
time that this is for the next
decade or maybe two decades some place I
would call home so the Journey from
Kiel to Freiburg II was killed two
Hamburg
will come to an end and now I have a
family and now this is this is for the
for the years I can overview the place I
will live and then I decided to become a
party member and be engaged in politics
so this this
um this is this was the step and the
rest happened just by chance if you if
you if you say yes
then you easily get a career in German
politics okay but you never but you
always have to say yes so if someone is
asking you you want to become our local
party leader yes I will okay you want to
become our uh
yeah so you want to go to the
conferences yes and then
then it's just but it was something with
a bicycle lane wasn't it I mean yeah
well the the main reason is all politics
is local I think it's not this is the
story everyone knows or not everyone but
a lot of people know that there was we
had very small village we lived in a
very small village and the neighboring
Village was something like three
kilometers away and all the children
going to school drove on the on the
landfillment the the normal the normal
street but because it was on the village
a lot of agricultural traffic was on it
I think it was
use value it was it was really dangerous
for for the kids driving cycling to
school there so because there was a bike
lane missing I thought it's a good idea
to go to the greens
well now I'm Vice Chancellor and the
bike lane is still missing so
but but I think to be honest I I
think the decision being engaged then
that's time in local politics this is
where I started I was the first party
leader and then the floor leader after a
communal election was was made anyway so
even with the bike lane I think I would
have
gone into politics but that time I would
never have called it politics just
engagement in any form as so many other
people are doing it
just one step back to roskill because
there are many students here listening
to this event
what kind of impact did Australia have
upon your sort of life in a particular
would you recommend students here to to
go abroad maybe a leading question to go
abroad I would always recommend and we
had to discuss about this earlier the
day where I think the leader of the
Youth Organization of the Steelers or
metal workers was with us and he asked
us or me
why don't they why isn't there an
Erasmus Exchange program for not only
for students but also for the people in
education so the ones working with their
hands
and actually I think there's no really
good answer for that so the one thing I
take with me a lot of things I take with
me from the day but this one thing is uh
asking the ones
responsible for education and European
relations why shouldn't we widen up the
Erasmus program so I think this is quite
unfair even if they don't if this is not
fitting to their life plan then we have
a program and nobody will use it but
this is no harm so let's do that
um yes I I would recommend take your
time I really think that
Germany and maybe also Denmark I can't
speak for Denmark I think it's a little
bit
the education system and maybe the view
on on
being young is a little bit more
different in Denmark but this can also
be because I tend to romanticize Denmark
so I don't know if this is true but in
Germany we we had a discussion 15 20
years ago where the main point was our
young people are too old when they get
into jobs and then there was a huge
pressure to reduce the school time
reduce this the time in University then
we skipped civil not civil military
service so at least boys they graduated
from school in the age of 19 I was 19
when I made my student exam ABI tour
then I served one and a half year
civil service that time so I neglected
military I said yeah
and then I was I think 21 and a half or
something like that then I started
University then I was 26 when I made my
my uh when I met my first exam so this
is the normal case but now people are
leaving school at the age of 17 there's
no military
in Germany
um
so they start start University they
graduate with Bachelor after three years
then they are 20 and Bachelor counts as
a full full
degree in University
and then they start working and my
personal feeling I mean it's your life
do whatever you want but I think you can
take a little bit more time and
experience the world and yourself and do
something that is giving you more
knowledge than just reading books
yeah yeah
no in 2021 one before the election but
this was this was I wrote it in the
covet 1990 pandemic time this was the
big thing ended for me it sounds like
this was another
another world actually so this was
before Russian aggression Before the War
of the crime before I became minister
before this uh horrific 2022 so
it seems It's a new book but it seems
like
I hope you find it interesting oh yeah
yeah no yeah definitely
um but there's one part in the
apartment that's dropped me you are
Southern Germany you've just been out
campaigning I think there's an election
in Bavaria as far as I remember
September yes and you take the train
from Sal and Durham to Northern Germany
and it's the very same day where Germans
shut down due to covet
and use by coincidence you meet a man on
Hamburg who said The Following
dish
one should shoot you
how on Earth do you explain this hate
and would you then recommend to young
people here of entering politics or
maybe even business people who like to
be queer and Steiger and to start a blue
career yeah this was actually the
starting point of writing a book because
so many things happened together this
was it was the first day of the real
covid-19 crisis hitting Europe and I was
in the full hurry campaigning in in
Bavaria and we had the the the end of
the campaign should have been a big
party celebration you can call it on the
place where Bayern mentioned normally is
celebrating their football championships
yeah implants and then we we
um we we set it off and uh I was trying
to get a night train back to the north
and I got the last available ticket and
I was a little bit concerned that I
can't find sleep because everyone is
smoking around me and doing parties and
then I was alone in the whole train I
think a lot of business men and maybe
women were traveling with a train and
they all stayed at home so I was alone
it was very
it was I can't say funny situation like
it was in a way
falling out of normality and then I
realized that something is happening now
something
astonishing and so I was in a
how do you say it I was in an open mind
mood yeah so I know that something is
happening but I couldn't really grasp it
and then this uh these small incident
happened at the hamburger someone told
me that he wants to see me dead which is
uh I think the wish of some Germans at
the moment
um but that time it was so direct and in
this open mind that I just had the
question okay I don't know the man he
does not know me I think I'm a decent
guy I haven't done him any harm why on
Earth is he saying that to me and this
was the starting point for the book so I
had more time than normal because
covid-19 I was not traveling anymore and
then I I approved the book and answering
that question was the main target of the
book what is what is splitting our
society apart what is the root the real
root for populism and what can you do
against it and how can I
not be part of the split of society I
mean I think of myself and my party and
the government that we try to fix
everything but I know very well that
I've been seen as part of the problem
from the other side so the other side
which other side how can you
how can how can I create another site as
being the one who's trying to unite the
country is maybe too much to say that at
least creating a majority for climate
action and social justice and
pro-european attitude so this is a
question hard to answer actually so but
then I had the time to reflect on it and
the main reason for this hate
yeah I think there's not one one one
reason alone of course there are
tendencies in society and politics I
think that the social media are
well to say it politely at least
making everything louder people are very
fast in twittering and having them
having and you left making up their
opinion even before they have read the
full article or have listened to the end
so this is from my perspective
loving books and the long story not the
best thing ever happened to social
debate maybe social media is even the
wrong word and it's more on social media
um so there are different
attendances we have right now but the
the structure problem from my point of
view and this is what the book is mainly
about is more complex and I hope it's
not too irritating but the main problem
is uh
that maybe I can phrase it I start with
the phrase Obama has said when he left
office
and I personally think he was a great
president and
and an adorable politician
but he when he left office and this I
think is counting even more for for why
I think he was a great politician he was
asking his staff what if we were all
wrong yeah
and I think he meant
what if
I myself
am creating a problem what if me the
first
Afro-American president made Donald
Trump possible but on the other hand
what what should he have done I mean
should a country always say okay then
better not have another American
president
you don't go into politics don't engage
in Progressive politicians in
Progressive politics so you can't say
okay then
stay out of it but the complex question
is how do you how do you create
freedom and Progressive
Society without
splitting the society without
losing the ones who are skeptical and
made there's nothing wrong with
skepticism but if skepticism and
critique becomes hate and populism then
we have a problem so this is it's it's
really a complex issue so and and then I
try on the next 250 pages to find some
answers
[Music]
see what I would like to also debate
here climate policy operasy I think we
also need to cover Russia and Putin and
also Europe
if we start with climate policy
I remember when I was Minister I was
dreaded when the new UN report would
come out because it would say once again
that it's five minutes to 12. or maybe
even worse and well now just this week
we had another report coming out and the
headline was the clima bomber ticked
well this is not a surprise no but but
how do we then get I mean support
for climate action we get all these
reports constant ly but I mean what
actually
say to you well at least
on the German home pages of all the big
public houses speak inside and so on I
think it's the same in Denmark there is
a ticking clock now so there's we have
six and whatever year's time and the
minutes are counting down maybe not
minutes but days at least so
I mean everyone everyone who is
surprised that the time is ticking must
be blind actually
so this is not a surprise the good thing
is that I mean this is the 5.5 the 1.5
degree that is the measure and I think
the chance that we meet the 1.5 Target
is very very little so it's not
impossible
but it would I would be surprised
actually if that would happen the good
thing is
we don't know exactly where the Tipping
Point is so it might be with 1.5 degrees
this is what all the experts say that it
could well be 1.6 so there's there's
even if we are like running out of time
there's no reason to stop acting because
there is a fair chance that even though
we are late and we are lazy and we have
missed so many opportunities and
and so many things are not happening
fast enough it's worth all the strength
to do whatever you can because
there is a chance that this is still
enough and
so the Tipping Point basically means
that after that we are not talking about
1.6 or 1.7 degrees then we're talking
about three or four degrees if the
climate is collapsing then I mean the
world is collapsing yeah this is this is
what we're talking about we're not
protecting the climate we're always
saying we are protecting the climate but
the climate does not care I mean the
climate is actually the sum of all
weather phenomenas even if it's two or
four degrees warmer what we are talking
about is our own lives we are protecting
humanity and human life on Earth so
there's all good reason to to be engaged
in it even though the clock is ticking
and this is what gives me
strength and motivation so we don't know
really if um
maybe 1.5 is is the limit but maybe it's
1.6 and a half so let's try to come as
close as possible and uh and that is
that I think is a very good motivation
in your book you race a very important
question I quote how do you imagine to
create bold and Progressive politics
without ignoring that progress and the
courage to change make many people turn
away turn away even Revolt or this is
the question I just try to exactly yeah
and although you just said that the book
uh couple of years old it seemed this
sentence seems rather up to date I would
say because seen from Denmark one could
say that you now as a minister you are
caught between a rock and a hard place
on the one hand you have the
conservative Ripple voters and the
editor of the Tabloid build side room
who protest heavily against waving
goodbyes to the combustion engine and
the oil and gas heating system at home
and on the other side of the spectrum
well you also have the climate stickers
Friday for future and so forth who claim
that nothing is happening so how on
Earth
can you handle that this is
yeah
I hope I can handle it actually so
um but but I can describe the phenomena
that is happening in Germany maybe it's
worse well definitely is it has happened
there you can you can always see it
clear clear when you look at it from a
distance so what happened in the U.S
campaign Donald Trump against Biden was
that the Republicans were trying to make
the climate issue to a cultural issue so
it's not an objective it's not something
we all have to
handle with it's something reserved for
cultural minorities something like
the way we eat the way we make do
holidays the way we travel the way we
talk whatever the way we dress ourselves
and if this is successful then only few
have to care for climate action and the
other one other ones are doing whatever
they do and they criticize the ones who
are taking care of climate action and I
think I hoped actually that in the past
years we learned that this is not the
right attitude that there's not one
responsibility from one party or one
minister or one sector but it's it's an
it's in so it's in Social it's a society
issue actually and everyone has to do
in his or her ability but as possible
like
um standing up for democracy you would
never argue that only a liberal party
has to has to watch out for democracy
and the other ones are doing whatever
they do they're doing business they are
they're doing Transportation but
democracy is something that is not
interesting for us you would never never
argue in that way so and I think we had
we have been there in the 2019 to 2021
yes
and then the war came and
maybe you can say that Europe was never
so United
in the past three decades maybe during
that time and like it's for me it's it's
feeling it feels like a reaction to this
Unity that we are now falling apart and
these
culturalization of of society issues
begins in you and uh and this is my
theoretical explanation but I heard when
you was the moderation was saying now
we're today we're tonight we're trying
to think
um so this is my thought about it and um
and how do I handle it and how how what
what is my part in the game well knowing
that I'm coming from the green party and
for a lot of people I'm
the threat of the economy
um they're both robots I try to I tried
to argue in the same way we're now
talking that this is not it's not
possible to solve the issue alone even I
would say it's dangerous to do that not
only dangerous to The Climate which is
not caring for climate action because
it's the climate but for our security
maybe you can also say for our economic
growth because the rest of the world at
least the big powers are heavily
investing into climate neutral
Technologies so if we are continuing the
old black path it's bad for everyone so
and we will see if I can succeed with
the augmentation
gave it into a couple of days
on German television where
rather disappointed to put what's
happening in your government you said we
have a mandate to do something for the
people for Germany at the moment we are
not doing enough
was that kind of a wake-up call I mean
to
in German politics in a way yeah
in what way then
well if you want someone to wake up you
tend to think he's sleeping or she's
sleeping
so yes well I I mean we we have a
intense debate to put it to life
politely in the government
and this is also something and why are
you actually debating just I mean
everything everything and this is also
fine yeah thank you and debate is
something good
but sometimes we have to come to an end
and make a decision so in Eternal debate
it's not not it's not politics and um so
but but my experience is that if things
are really getting stuck you have to to
you have to change the level you have to
you have to create a new
form of discussion to make it possible
to solve other things
and this was the attempt to to play my
part into that to to say we also
publicly
to say this is this is not what we we
went into government
and we will see what's happening on
Sunday and Sunday we'll have so-called
Coalition shows it's like it's a meeting
we have regularly where
Denmark okay and the where the party
leader and leading ministers are coming
together and and and try to
I don't know balance the discussions and
the government so this is regularly
meeting and now we have to have to
solve some problems okay so we'll skip
that odd on Sunday and um
because this will definitely last a
little bit longer than hard art okay and
I hope it's not uh live
um live broadcasting out of the rooms we
are sitting in yeah okay I can imagine
that this would be fun for some of you
but um yeah yeah then then I can assure
you we won't find any solutions because
I know there's a there's a need for
transparency but my experience is you
also need rooms for maneuver you need
some private sphere also politics I mean
if everything is public then in a in the
public office everything is under the
perspective who wins and who loses so if
if there's no room where you can test
some some movements so imagine I would
give you that what would you give me and
what do you need and how can I help you
and you're not and you and you're afraid
that this discussion becomes public and
everyone is writing he offered help is
this guy crazy he does not helpful
politics were is working then it never
happening it's never happening so we
need some
some some room where we can discuss
openly and this is difficult enough
yeah but um I think it's the only
solution that we also there I would
argue that we have to lift the level of
ambition we have to change the the the
the the nivo in a way
yeah and one shouldn't leak there's
proposals
well I understand it's the same
um it's the same agreement it's it's a
conflict of interest in a way of course
there's an interest of the public and
maybe also of the media there are some
media experts here in the room to have
information early but if you have it
then this information early and this is
the race of the media and the
politicians have the feeling of some in
politics maybe it wasn't politicians
have the feeling that their own value
depends on giving secret information
earlier in the media then this room
where you can
show your partners
some information becomes smaller and
smaller and then solution is not
possible so
um I I mean it's it's what the media is
doing and
in a way I can say this is their job but
I can personally say for myself it's
only me Robert speaking
um for me the Articles where someone has
some secret information are not the most
interesting and not the best pieces of
Journalism so I would like to read the
explanations the long Stories the
interpretation of our society of our
politics of what is going on in Europe
so
um that might be also a success without
having secret information and this hunt
for for leakage and and politics I hope
so talking about success I mean your
government has managed to agree upon a
number of things well this is this is
the Scenic the synonym about it I think
we are doing really really good or we
have done really really good as a
government we
last year
I I don't know if you know it but
Germany's dependency on Russian fossil
fuel was
skyrocking High
55 of our natural gas was coming from
Russia this was mainly going into the
households for heating and in the
industry
we had 55 or 50 of our coal coming from
Russia coal is for the steel industry
and for
sorry to say also for the electricity
sector and uh one third of all of our
oil was coming from Russia so this is
and everything is gone now and we solved
it without a breakdown of the economy
right now the storages are full the
prices are going down the inflation has
reached its top we see a modest rate of
growth it's not there where I want it
but we there was a threat a real threat
of an abyss
also all the discussions about
uh
I'm in covid-19 the GDP rate was going
down minus five maybe five a half and a
half percent
the prediction in Germany was or some
predicted that if we lose the Russian
gas we would see a decline of GDP of -12
so
twice the crisis of the covid-19
pandemic that would really be a shock so
this was what was the threat and this
was a real threat it's not it's not
fairy tale so this was the reality last
year and all the nervousness and all the
um
pressure under which we acted was was
because this was a reality and we banned
it by with Extraordinary Measures we I
remember reading that you basically said
that one should not take a hot shower or
Lisa you were not taking small measures
people people saved
yeah but it worked
um we were we would not have been able
to fill up the storages without the help
of the people I mean this is something
this is an extraordinary story I think
it's the same in Denmark you saved
energy minus 16 17 percent less energy I
mean if we would do that all the time we
would solved a lot of CO2 uh time
ticking problems but of course there was
also
um Industries who reduced the energy
consumption and that was because they
reduced production so you could you
could see what will happen if there was
no gas but now there is no gas and we
have solved the problem by spending a
lot of money by nationalizing Juniper by
talking to the people by going to Qatar
by yeah but this was not so so
successful it's only one deal and this
is only two two BCM so this was not
really a big help but uh
anyway
um well at least you didn't go to the
football match
we even did for me the hardest decision
is we had a we had a reserve of coal
power plants very old cold power plants
nobody wanted ever to use them again but
to safeguards we brought them in to the
electricity Market again and still in
2022 the CO2 emissions in Germany
decreased so I was I was surprised
actually to read that because because of
all the unpopular measures I thought
bringing back six and a half gigawatt
cold power plants would definitely lead
to a higher production rate of CO2 but
it didn't so this was a very very
successful year and I doubt that
um now I don't say that but I I think I
think we have really done a good job
there
we have made mistakes obviously if you
take decisions without preparation and
we were really in a hurry it was the I I
really can I can remember so many
moments that I thought Okay this may
might be the first free weekend after I
don't know six weeks or seven weeks and
then someone called me and say you know
there's no Russian gas coming where the
pipeline has exploded or
udepa has just given them public
declaration they're losing every day 200
million euros they will collapse in five
days time in five days time so do
something and I mean we're talking about
30 billion euros to stabilize this
company and no party party convention
has ever discussed it there was no
preparation for it so we we we we we get
that on the phone we talked it through
and then we acted and and this at the
end it all went well but tragically
nobody is talking about that and we
haven't gained strengths out of it now
we are talking about
other things but maybe there's a chance
that we can come back to the old Spirit
on Sunday this is my idea
and since we are in Denmark when you
give talks
which I sometimes do in Germany and
energy policy then very quickly at a
certain stage you have to answer the
following question what about nuclear
energy is it now total hoses or what
will happen in Germany no we in I think
three weeks time the last three nuclear
power plants will get off the grid and
that's it and that's it yeah no more
debate about nuclear energy in Germany
small debate I would say and why explain
to the audience why is that a wise
decision
um it's a it's a decision uh that was
taken by the Markle liberal government
in 2020 in 2011 after Fukushima which
doesn't necessarily make it a wise
decision but yeah I think it's a wise no
but it's a it's a decision that led to
consequences the scale-up of renewable
energy and new grid infrastructure and a
lot of spending was done because of that
I personally think that there are a lot
of unsolved problems we don't know what
to do with the waste we have a process
in Germany
to find the storage for the nuclear
waste the story this the planes go like
this until 2020 until 2030
we want to have
um
is no wait I have to think about it I
think we we want to find the place where
we do the storage until 2030 then it
takes something like 20 years to to
build up the commands so it's it's a
construction under under down down but
you say in the earth you wherever we do
it and then we start bringing the
nuclear waste into the storage in 2020
in 2050 and this takes 30 years yeah so
when my children are asking me when have
you when are you rid of the problem I
would say gladly I answered the best
guess in uh 2020 in 2080
this is the reality now and this is the
best case and now imagine how long World
War II is gone
and then you see 20 20 80 so this is
definitely not a technique that in any
form relies to the phrase responsibility
we have created a problem we are not
able to solve and our politician
political responsibility
not talking about
nuclear threat and cows and attacks and
so on so on but
um personally I think I'm also Minister
for economic affairs and not only for
energy and climate action
that nuclear energy is one of the more
expensive forms of energy so there are
compared to win and so on so compared to
wind and solar the Investments we know
about the last investments in France
flanville in Great Britain Hindi point
in Finland with a name I can't pronounce
um they they uh these are the three the
last three power plants in Europe and
the construction time was always
estimated with five years and it always
took longer than 20 and the price tree
doubled from an estimation of 6 billion
to
also 20 billion meaning that the price
for electricity over a period of maybe
30 years 40 years would be
12 maybe 15 Euro Cent we produce
renewable energy now for a price of
three to maybe seven or six Euro Cent
and this the scale down of the price the
decline of the price is not coming to an
end so to the to to my French friends I
always say okay fair enough it's
competition Europe relies on competition
bring it on we meet 2030 and we will see
who has the more efficient and cheap
energy and they are smiling and go back
to the nuclear Fleet
and
and this is not these are not new
nuclear power plants the old ones
and old ones
who that were created for 40 years time
and they have now prolonged the period
of of usage for additional 20 years or
something like that
so
I'm interested to see what's uh who will
Who will achieve the better Energy
System and I'm quite sure and I hope I'm
aligned with Denmark here because you're
doing this actually doing exactly the
same you're not create building a new
nuclear power plant in Denmark I heard
there were rumors that the discussion is
also in Denmark but don't do it if you
want to my point of view because not
because it's dangerous that you have to
decide on your own but I'm convinced
that it's the economic sense is in
renewable energy and clean and cheap uh
renewable energy and this is this is the
future
let's move to the tragic war in Ukraine
obviously that's not part of your book
um
but the 24th of February
I read the other day that you were
actually informed by The Americans
we're in a meeting and then certainly
you got some papers that you was yeah my
colleague Catherine Tai the minister for
trade boss in Berlin and we met and when
we left the office there was part of the
embassy with her staff of the embassy
and they gave me an envelope and see
okay tonight is going to happen
and uh
well that's that was a time when
everyone was aware that that could
happen but reading that they're now
um using their blood conserves that they
are painting the sets and the tanks that
they are opening up the the heads of the
of the rockets and uh that was something
else so this in a way this now was
becoming very very concrete
and yeah so this is true and there was
absolutely no preparation in Germany
because you already covered that yeah of
course I think but I mean can you
prepare for an extra no but maybe you
could have thought about being so
dependent upon Russian gas okay no but
but the you know I can tell the story
because it's public the the head of the
German secret service they predicted
that this was just a military
yeah yeah so there won't be a war and he
was on his way to Kiev When The War
started so he was stuck in Ukraine
because he believed his own files
and they were wrong so of course there
was an awareness that that could happen
but the German intelligence argued it it
will not happen this is only a minor
maneuver or maybe there might be a local
conflict but not a full-scale war and
um so the Americans had other
informations and they gave them to me on
that night
and the the thing
I would say the tragic thing about the
storages is Germany has the use the the
the highest capacity for gas storages in
Europe
one
quarter of our annual gas consumption we
can store under the Earth
so if we would get any guess at all we
would last three months about three
months so this is quite a capacity and
we sold it
part of it to gasp from
as we thought also some part of our oil
refugees to rosnift and the thing is we
saw them in the year 2015 and 2016. so
after Crimea after Crimea one year after
the first Ukraine war if you can call it
like that I mean it's not a Ukraine war
it's actually a Russian war but you know
what I mean
[Music]
um
and that's now at least from our
knowledge raises the question how stupid
can you be so and I guess that also goes
for node stream too yes absolutely this
is the the third part of the story uh in
2015 nostring one was already in
operation but then the German government
made the decision because
we
rely on Russia after the criminal War
the occupation of Crimea we want to have
a second pipeline this was Northern two
also in the year 2015.
and the
also this is public then I cannot can I
I can also tell it in Denmark the form
of getting an application
to operate North stream 2 is it's two
steps the second step is that our energy
agency has to check the unbundling so is
there is it a European operator and so
on so they are doing the technical
checks in a way
the first step is that you have a
political check if this infrastructure
could be a threat to the German public
and actually the argumentation is on on
the first hand not so easy to give why
should an additional capacity of
energy infrastructure should be a threat
it can be a threat if the dependency
becomes too big this is the lesson we
have learned now
and this was the question raised by a
paper that was arguing no there is no
threat and if you read this paper I read
it in over the Christmas days of 2021
when I was Minister I was three weeks in
office then that time
uh even that time that's what was before
the Russian aggression started there
were so many open questions if you read
this paper now it's it's on the homepage
it's public now
you won't believe it so it's it's it's
really unbelievable and
yeah so they this was a political
decision and it was unwise to say the
least
and there's been lots of criticism I
would say also in Denmark if one now
looks upon Germany's role after the
invasion started I'm referring to the
sort of very slow process delivering
weapons to to Ukraine I mean I'm just
referring now to debate what the debate
has been like but what I thought was
really interesting I mean when one looks
upon your
sort of decision to go to Ukraine
during the election Camp just before the
election campaign last time because if
you went at a time where nobody in
Denmark let's just be Frankie debated
Ukraine but you decided before the last
election to go to donbass right and you
actually also came back saying that
Germany should deliver weapons yeah but
the stories I met zelenski he visited
Berlin when he was elected was elected
president
in 2019 yeah something like that and um
well there's a unwritten law that
government members don't meet party
leaders so government meets government
and party meets party and
parliamentarian groups meet
prelimitarians and but zielinski for
reasons I still haven't fully grabbed
insisted on meeting me and
that was
a very open Moment from the beginning so
we
it felt good to talk to each other this
was 2019 so he was a young elected
president and and I was only party
leader and still we
well there was a dynamic and he said
please come to Ukraine and then 2021 I
had the chance and the time to go
Ukraine to Ukraine so this was the story
then I'd I visited Kiev I met
zelinski as well we had the same open
Friendly talks he explained that he has
done also to me in 2019 that Ukraine and
he under his leadership wants to be a
part of Europe he is pro-european he
wants to fight corruption in this
country he gave me the feeling that he
wants to be one of us one of the young
political leaders that trying to change
the continent for the better being
climate neutral being part of the
progressive leadership that is that
still is possible I think and
with this impression that there was a
serious guy that was a time when a lot
of people thought he's just an actor
exactly comedian yeah comedian and an
actor but I never felt this way and then
I traveled in the in the donbass I was
in Mario pool and uh well I met the
Ukraine troops there they told me that
they
were losing men maybe also women but
mainly men I think over the year like 20
because the Russian snipers had their
last
education days at the Russian Ukraine
border and they could always tell which
troops were now training on them because
some were shooting in the direct in the
head somewhere shooting in the eye and
some were shooting in the in the throat
so they know exactly which part of the
Russian sniper
Elite shoe whatever we're now at the
border so this was the reality and they
taught me stories and showed me pictures
of drones just small drones like we can
buy in in in in the supermarket
with landmines on it or some other forms
of explosive they were they were flying
the drones over the border and dropping
whatever explosives they had Into The
Gardens of the houses and then
children were playing women were doing
something in the garden and boom there
were losing legs or lives so this was
the reality they were they they told me
and then what should I do I I was asking
them so any form of help and they said
yes give us weapons that we can shoot
down the drones from the sky and uh
having telenski's words in my ear and
knowing that all of Europe was saying
Ukraine belongs to Europe and you the
maidan was an opera Opera for real
so freedom and and and
all the big words but no help no offer
to be part of Europe no real offer and
and if you talk to the soldiers some of
them dying there at least losing
comrades or the
the people living in dambas
and you are I was asked by a media
should are you are you supporting
the delivery of weapons that they can
protect themselves better and then to
say as my party has made the decision no
because
they are fighting for the freedom and
they are part of the Free World but and
they're dying and we could help them
because we have the weapons to shoot
down the drones but we won't
give them because we have a party
decision
and because how can I do that and
because so I said yes of course and then
um uh I still have the the
um
the snapshots of all the discussions so
a lot of politicians that are now
again just forget it
so it wasn't but Germany was not ready
to deliver weapons that's at that time I
can say
and the consensus that we have now in
Germany will that hold if you look upon
it politically absolutely absolutely so
Germany will continue all the Divine
weapons to to Ukraine there's now a
shift yes and we have done it with a in
a great amount so I know that the image
Maybe
in parallel to the image of the
Coalition is not so good because we had
the long ongoing discussions about
leopard tanks but if you look at the
numbers we are one of the biggest
suppliers also military for Ukraine and
the because we are the Germans and we
are so correct we always count the value
of the weapons for the for the real
value so if we send over 20 year old uh
Mara thanks we're not saying there are
new model tanks we're saying that 20
years it's like an old car so actually I
think the numbers com other countries
are doing that not they are they are
counting like there were new weapons and
so actually there's I don't think we
should
um we there's nothing it took the
leopard decision took a little bit too
long but the amount of Supply we have
delivered
is something I'm I'm really satisfied
with
but this nivida
of a war was that one of the reasons why
it was so difficult for Germany to
deliver the web I think so yes because
this knee Vida was connected to the to
Russia
and Ukraine well I think it's a good
it's something good that you hesitate to
deliver weapon so I'm I'm also
responsible for the delivery of weapons
now we are selling into the world and I
think of myself as an ambitious Minister
I want to achieve many things climate
action we talked about renewable energy
scale up whatever but I don't want to be
I don't have any ambition to be the
minister who's selling the most weapons
to the world so
I think you should be careful
and
still and I mean you know the German
history so
I I have great respect for the people
who are saying that
they can't raise the hand for delivering
weapons to Ukraine I come to other
conclusions but my respect they have as
long as they are not saying
Putin is a nice nice guy and they are
pro-russian I think this is that would
be a terrible mistake so the the ethical
consequences also the political
consequences are clear if Putin's wins
whatever this means wins this war no
country in Europe is ever safe from of
Russian aggressions this is an
invitation for Putin to
to attack the next country maybe start
the next phase of war in Ukraine and
this is also an invitation for other
dictators to use military means to to to
create a new political landscape so this
is not an option
but um
the moral
rigidness of people saying I can't be
part of of a military conflict this is
not in me
this is something I fully respect this
is not true that I mean these are heavy
weapons with every decision we are taken
I personally take people are getting
killed this is completely clear to me so
this is this is a heavy decision and if
someone is not wanting or able to take
the decision
this is that's something I can
understand
but the argument that we won't this was
this is the German not law it's not a
law but it's a directive and this was
also my party line
the argument that we won't deliver
weapons in Conflict zones
that I never understood because in a
conflict you always have an aggressor
and someone that is a victim and being
neutral to that situation
means you shut your eyes and you don't
look at that so I think the right answer
if you're not
if you if you're not so peace loving
that you can't raise your hand for
delivering weapons so like Mahatma
Gandhi yeah this is this is something
great I fully respect and the Deep wish
for for peace is fully accepted so the
right tone in the debate is sometimes
also missing for them who have the need
for
who are who are talking about peace so
sometimes I have the feeling that
there's not enough room in the debate
for a more reflected way even though
this is not my my my personal meaning I
I wonder have this discussion it's a
necessary discussion so not being
hawkish all the time and saying more and
more and more weapon there must be room
for
the tiny voices that we're talking about
peace it's over now no no yeah just uh
you have enough we had Energy Efficiency
before and now they're just uh
so but the but if you say I'm I'm I'm
willing to deliver weapon yeah weapons
but not in zones of conflict that is an
argument I don't understand so let's
make it concrete I mean we have shifted
our party line completely we are now
delivering weapons to Ukraine which is
right but the argument in Swiss for
example is exactly like the argument
that my party the green party and also
the majority of the German politicians
had before the Russian aggression on
Ukraine we are not delivering weapons in
the conflict Zone
and
I mean what is that
um I mean for me it's hard to understand
how you can stay neutral in times of
fascism which is also part of the Swiss
history but now
now saying we this is only about
ammunition so you know that we have uh
gephards some other form of tanks in
Ukraine the ammunition is gone now
Swiss has it it's not they don't have to
deliver weapons they only give us the
allowance to deliver ammunition to the
gapas and they won't because they say no
we stay neutral staying neutral and
making businesses so this is something I
kind of I don't like
when I go to Berlin I always go to the
big bookstore dusman right
yeah it's open all night yeah it's open
yeah it's wonderful it's wonderful yeah
even if you spend your Saturday night in
there and that's fascinating
um but I remember sort of going there
about 10 years ago and it was always
striking compared to Danish bookstores
how many books you had about about
Russia and also Russian authors
we basically don't have that and but now
what really struck me when I go there
again now I can see all this Ukrainian
literature and all these books about
Ukraine and then sort of being half
German I went to the school around the
corner here San Pedro and I simply
cannot remember that I was told anything
about Ukraine and Germany's special
responsibility towards Ukraine Holocaust
with bullets and so forth it was Russia
Russia Russia Russia so is there
something in the way
that that we've basically looked upon
Russia that made us not realize that
Ukraine was a separate nation yeah in a
way this is true because and this this
is also an explanation for
some
politicians and I think it's a good
explanation it's an honorable
explanation in the years of the Cold War
it was the social Democrats who changed
under holy brunt the attitude towards
Russia to us politicians
politique and you know that he went to
Vassar and he kneeled in New Town then
if I and also there were now diplomacy
diplomatic they tried to build up
diplomatic strings with Russia and
energy was one of the strings so the
first relation established a new where
was energy
and I think
the lesson this is a good tradition I
mean why should you not work for peace
why should you not try to help people by
building up diplomatic relationships at
that time
and of course the left part of the
German politics is
um there might have been the time where
they have thought America is too
capitalistic and social
socialistic governments are
interesting
so there's also maybe a personal
affection or something like this is a
created image then don't forget that
part half of the not half of the German
population but
the gdr is only 30 years gone so we have
population that was taught that Russia
is the friend so this is in them so
maybe like you saying you think Sweden
and you are part of the northern family
um you would also be imagine there would
be a conflict in the in this
Scandinavian region it would be very
hard for you to to to even to to to to
guess to grab what is going on so
this is all
fair to say to to accept that people
have different histories that their
education that their political
socialization is part of the problems
now that people have and I personally
once again I I honor these reasons if
one is talking to me and saying to me I
see I see that it's not good what's
happening there but
I spent half of my life in the gdr I was
always taught that Russia as a friendly
country and we should look to Russia as
a partner don't expect me now to deliver
weapons to Ukraine to shoot on the
Russians I can't do that I would in a
way accept it and there are sociology
Democrats even now in the German
Parliament who are exactly saying that
still they're doing the right decisions
but you can you can see it
in the way they behave that they are
suffering that's not an easy easy
decision for them
because it's so much part of them so but
coming to to the to the German history
in Ukraine Russia Belarus Poland
this is really complicated and we have
so much guilt on our shoulders that we
really can't
draw a lesson out of it I mean we we
attacked we means Germany the fishes
Germany we attacked Russia Ukraine
Poland we murdered millions of people
but both in Russia and in Ukraine so
there's no lesson to be learned out of
our historical obligation to one or the
other countries so I but it's it's so
complicated you you don't know where to
start to to to explain what has happened
there and
so I think this
there's no of course you can learn a
lesson out of History this is of course
true in but getting a clear advice
because of the German Guild guild in
World War II how to behave in this
conflict is simply not possible I think
because it's too complicated we have
done so many bad things there both in
both countries you can't say we have to
support Ukraine because we have murdered
deaf people their Jews as well because
we also murdered millions of Russians
you can't say we have to stay away
because we attacked Russia once there
were German tanks driving towards Moscow
you can't say that because then you
leave the Ukraine side out away so this
is there's no easy lesson learned out of
the The Guild is two two two big but it
obviously always plays a role you could
say yeah it plays a role in a conflict
and many many people have and this is
some once again this is
I think this is something that has a
value in itself that people have moral
restrictions and they they are thinking
about it
but this is not the same as saying Putin
is a nice guy and there's no I can't
differentiate between Ukraine and Russia
this is not the same so my respect for
all the ones who who have inner
conflicts and and have not they don't
have it in them to make
a military decision right now
but this is not the same we are now
seeing when finished the left-wing
politician is going to the street and
trying to explain the people that
actually the Ukraine have started the
war or the ukraines are fulfilling
American
politics so this is just this is
something else so no respect for that
in Germany when you have a
in Germany when you have a discussion
about a book the author always reads a
paragraph he says what I've experienced
it's not in Danish so yeah I know so
I've found here on page 358 a six
yeah I made it onto page three thousand
three hundred not three thousand three
hundred fifty eight so if you start
there
okay new classes with English
you all understand German
so two Germans speaking English on a
Danish scenes
you're being too optimistic I would say
so Luca asked me to read a short
paragraph out of the book and it's uh
going like this
as I try to explain referring to World
War II uh
foreign
Jesus land is
and the Very sort of
short translation of that is obviously
there's no time in German history which
is better than the one we're
experiencing now
I think so yes
and could you elaborate on that is that
the entire Germany does that also go for
Eastern Germany yes especially when you
look upon if you if you think about the
last
I know the years after World War II
especially for Eastern Germany I know
that people are in East Germany are
sometimes frustrated
but well I haven't lived in the gdr and
I guess there was also fun and people
laughed and met but from my point of
view being a West German green
politician so you have to ask otherwise
other people so I'm talking about
experiences I haven't I haven't I I'm
reflecting but I don't have experienced
it
especially for East Germany now the time
is better I mean there are conflicts and
there's poverty and now we want to face
out of lignite coal as well but still
it's a free country and people can vote
and can talk and can travel and can do
whatever they want so yes especially in
East Germany this counts
we started out with a roskill University
Center as it was called at that time
Ross now roskill University
we have many students here when I
studied political science the good old
days sort of the Berlin Wall tumbled
down and everything we had Central and
Eastern Europe joining the European
Union this is a rather different Europe
that the students now experience what
would be your sort of advice to them how
can they also influence and make an
impact the first advices don't listen to
advices of
old men or whatever
how old am I 50 53 year old politicians
and make your own experiences
but I can talk about Europe if you want
are you worried about
obviously I'd like to speak about Europe
what's your are you worried about the
development are you also can Europe
actually expand can we enlarge with a
country like Ukraine we'll also have
taken the West Balkans can we have a
European Union with
36 member states so first of all worry
or being void is not my state of mind
yes that might be definitely there will
come another time but now I'm one of the
ones who is responsible so there are
challenges and there are projects and
there are threats but being worried is
the wrong attitude it's now up to us to
solve the problems not sit there and say
oh I'm so worried but to find Solutions
and I hope they are the right ones
um and there are a lot of
um
a lot of problems to solve some of them
we we discussed tonight
that Europe
is collapsing is not my worry
actually I think especially in the last
year we learned that Europe is the
answer and not the problem and I hope
that not so many people forget it I
I mean we have a right-wing government
in Italy
but
on the European level they don't lead
Italy out of Europe they behave okay
not my political friends obviously but
they they know that would they will lose
all influence if they would drop out of
Europe or even make Europe impossible to
act the same goes with Poland
and even Victor R1 is not leaving the
European Union he's only
doing his pillar so
[Laughter]
um
the brexit was a mistake
and I think even in Great Britain this
is acknowledged now
the question is how can Europe you ask
me should you expand and I think yes the
answer is yes but reform so we promised
a lot of South birken Estates if you are
doing this or that you have a chance to
to come to Europe
and a lot of countries have done that
also under
big risk of political leaders imagine
that they
uh North Macedonian name conflict was
only solved because
the president put all his political
leverage in changing calling the country
north Macedonia and uh and um
and he was not really re-elected then so
a lot of people have done a lot of
things to
to unite Europe and if we would push
them away now after giving them the
promise as we have done to Ukraine
actually is that would be easy
turkey yeah into Turkey
um so that that's that would be a big
historical mistake we are living in a
Time the big story behind this all the
small stories is that geopolitics is
back again the time of an open One World
Trade sphere is not the situation we are
now facing
interests become power interest and
power interest become
military interest so if we are not using
our economic and
and also Democratic power to collect
Partners we are we are we're not
behaving as we should do so yes the
answer is yes we should be open for
other member states
but we must reform so and does that
imply a treaty change
in the end yes I think so but I know
that treaty changes must be acknowledged
by all the governments I mean you are a
pro-european country
even even becoming more pro-european
than than before if I see it right but
still you have the corner well that's
fine with me but you you know yeah it's
good to hear from the German minister of
economic economics I mean that's fine
but you know why yes or no it's it's
it's very easy to gain
to gain votes by campaigning against
something and I mean I'm coming from the
greens we have also a very European
skeptical history some of us at least
have so I it's I know a treaty change
would mean that all the member states
once again will vote for a European
Constitution
and there's no guarantee that this is uh
kind of happening
or happening successfully so but if I
can wish in the end we we come to
something like uh the Federal Union of
up countries with with the final
Democratic power of government and and
not a commission that is in for in the
form
indirect has a indirect Democratic
legitimation but well yeah so I think
there must be the idea of a finality of
the process
knowing that this is not on stage right
now so don't get me wrong I don't expect
a big reform of the European big reform
of the European Union right now and I
don't think that we have treaty changes
right now but we have to keep it in mind
that it's still this it is a possibility
and maybe also sooner or later in
necessity but this does not mean that
everything has to stay like it is so
the number of Commissioners the the
maybe some arrangements between the
countries this is possible I think and
there are I mean the way of Europe is
doing things
silently so there is reforms and they
right now in the energy crisis I think
all the countries now have accept that
Europe is in lead of organizing the the
overall Energy System this was not the
case one and a half years ago so
silently there was a development and
this is a good one
I think we will invite you back for a
discussion on Europe
because I think there are many items
there that we could discuss but our time
is up now thank you for this Deutsche
Thunder
kind of touched only you could say truly
appreciate it also that you spent your
time with us I mean you've been more or
less around the world and we was at
Brazil and it was Japan and it was
Colombia crazy week actually yeah and
now you have to have that very very
important meeting in the German
Coalition which we will follow after
we've seen tartort
um and talking about deutsched under I
had the pleasure uh many years ago
moderating Seafood lengths so he was
sitting in your chair here yeah here
here I never forget it because
afterwards his Danish wife from the Isle
of fruit and oh yeah right sent me
several years after Seafood lands had
died she sent me this book which was
published after his death it was
apparently a manuscript that they found
and then she wrote in the book a gift
from Seafood in the book don't worry I'm
not expecting the same to happen after
this talk but but I definitely hope that
you will at a certain time have time
again to write books I mean also novels
and then we will also invite you back to
speak about those so two attack
yeah oh wait a moment
um as you said the gift from Secret
there's one funny story I always
wondered about the word gift
and English oh yeah so being married
giving a present and being poisoned
always
yeah okay
thank you
thank you very much there won't be an
extra number
bye